anyone that knows they're hot and i
don't know what this is or maybe it's
some shame in me anyone that's like
really feeling themselves i'm a little
bit like it's just a little repellent it
is interesting the only thing worse than
that is someone's like i'm ugly and i'm
fat and they're not and you're like
you're stuck you know so well because
that's fishing for compliments for
somebody to be like you're not ugly
you're better yeah yeah yeah exactly i
like a nice middle ground like give me
both you're like i'm having a great hair
day but boy am i about to blow up this
bathroom afterwards you know like the
awareness of like i'm hot but i'm also
human yeah when um uh sarah silverman
recently uh posted about this um she
talked about in her podcast where
one time she changed my life because she
made me realize how annoying it is when
you self-deprecate around someone that's
trying to give you a compliment or you
won't just receive it even if you don't
agree with it just receive it someone's
giving you a gift and you're just like
throwing it in the gutter that's true so
we were outside um uh we were like did a
spin class or something so we're all
sweaty and disgusting and uh she was
like your skin is amazing or something i
was like oh it's that nightmare it's a
disaster i mean i just i don't even need
to punch and she just went
i think
the answer you're looking for is thank
you yeah and i was like
you know do you feel like you have to
give a compliment back if like if you're
like thank you and then you have to be
like oh well yeah you know because then
you know the only reason i'm giving you
this compliment because you just gave me
one so i'm gonna drop it on you fucking
out of nowhere that is interesting i
don't know why it tends to be
most most comedians will like kind of
like take the comment but yeah but even
if somebody's like yo great said you're
like yeah but you know that that that
part didn't work you know i don't know i
don't know why i need to do that i have
to i always do that because that's just
to me that's the article on stage this
is work we're at work we're at a job and
it is our job to assess our performance
and just go like yeah that i think i
need to change the order on that and
then
i think it's like you know when you were
just talking about when guys compliment
themselves like i'm so hot it's like
when you see a comet get off stage and
he's like oh i smashed i would never
like i've had sets the best i'll ever
say after said i was like oh they were
great i would be like they were great
they were fun but i'll never be like oh
i'm murdered oh i'm fucking
baltimore you've never seen a better
comedian like if you murdered we'll all
know yeah yeah
it is
but there's been plenty of times where
i've asked somebody and they'll be like
how are they like oh i smashed it's just
fun
you know what i'm saying you did your
job right you did your job that's not
smashed i killed i did my job that
everyone expected me to do so it's like
imagine any other job like you know
like
a surgeon whatever or who whatever who
does something yeah yeah someone's like
oh you
put his
that is the
uh least you are supposed to be doing
here tonight correct and that's why i
think if you if you want to compliment
yourself you put it on the audience but
oh they were great because you're saying
that like my material works for them if
that checks out
yeah i think it's more we're getting
granular yeah it doesn't matter
people were like yeah i talked about
tits again he said no i like it but it's
like well how do we get what we're
talking about we're like
i don't like your brain you're just very
self-aware you're incredibly smart um
your nose is just a like a
pussy wand um and
but noses there was a scientific study
that came out that guys with more
prominent noses are more attractive on
like a primordial level like
subconscious level you know who wrote
that a guy with a fucked up nose
[Music]
four four four five
[Applause]